in our earlier examples of comparing
different versions against one another
we just conveniently had those old
working versions sitting around in that
case we manually saved off old versions
under different file names I personally
used to do this all the time with school
essays math papers in law tech and so on
this is one very primitive form of
version control how else might you get
old versions of your files it's likely
that you've actually interacted with
some systems that do some form of
version control for you if you ever used
dropbox dropbox actually periodically
saves versions of your files after
you've edited a file you can right click
and choose view previous versions and
then in the browser you can check some
of the old versions note that by default
Dropbox only saves these versions for 30
days do you use Google Docs there's a
little link up at the top that says all
changes saved in Drive if you click on
that you get a side panel of all the old
revisions made by anyone who's ever
worked on the dock and you can restore
to any point in time what about
Wikipedia if you go to any Wikipedia
article say maybe the one on version
control you'll see a view history tab
you can click on to see all the old
versions you can click through to see an
entire old version or you can compare
any two versions against one another
let's take some time now for another
reflection